this machine is the leg press machine to
adjust the seat you pull the yellow
lever up and lower the seat or higher it
to where required
to change the weight you pull the yellow
pin out and place in your selected
weight
you can also push the increment in which
for this machine is five kilograms you
want to then equally place your feet
just wide of the circle at the same
height to then begin the movement as
demonstrated
you want to push off from the board
ensuring that you do not lock the knees
out in order to prevent injury
also important to maintain a good Tempo
throughout this movement in order to
keep tension going through the leg and
Soles
you can also have your legs at different
heights on the board
in order to Target different parts of
the legs
to Dismount the sheen take both legs off
turn and step off
foreign
[Music]